I know she's a yoga lesbian now dude
yeah straight up she's like married to a
woman and she's like a [__] yoga
person sometimes when you go yoga you go
lesbian
[Music]
so you guys know about the TV show what
is called Shark Tank yeah have you ever
been on it I've never been done oh
you're gonna be a shark you'd be a shark
on there huh yeah would you rather pitch
a business to them or would you rather
be a shark I'll be the shark for sure
damn I want to pitch a business oh great
what kind of business me too I want it
to be so [__] ridiculous that they
don't know that I'm [__] around
let's get it's a good troll like a good
[__] troll because the only only the
audience would know me like I mean like
our audience would know me so it's like
yeah would it be a VR machine set up
with like a you know what maybe I'll
make it like uh like I'll I'll come in
and I'll be like my business is called
great release and then they're like what
is this and it's like well okay uh
flatulence and indigestion and IBS and
all this is so it's a it's a thing
that's hurting Americans all over you
gotta say it's hurting you and me yeah
and you know there's always a story like
all right
the great release right so you come into
my center and then the [__] you get a
massage and then these these guys are
just [__] doing [__] yatsu on the
backing and you're [__] and farting
and like you're letting it go that's
really good because you're constipating
I'll give you 50 grand for ten percent
this is one of those things where Joe
starts to sweat because all the sharks
are out but Kevin's still in yeah and no
one wanted Kevin yeah and Kevin's like I
that's a great release I want to do a
royalty deal and then Joe's like oh [__]
I actually have to do this business
he's like oh God
so check it out uh Mr damond John has
filed a lawsuit in restraining order
against a former uh group of contestants
from Shark Tank why because they kept
bugging him well so they were blasting
him all over social media this group is
called the baker family they did uh I
don't know if you guys ever saw this
episode but I watched it for this they
did this episode called Bubba's
Barbecue's boneless baby back ribs and
they both this baby get back yeah
it's ribs and they're really good and
all this [__] the Sharks all tried it
they all really liked it you want the
bones though but they they got a deal
with him and he started FUBU and like
this yeah that guy the food dude yeah
it's huge right so then
um they say he was a douchebag like
working with him was a nightmare and
after and he says after repeated
attempts to give them like the ability
to correct their violations of our
agreement it's unfortunate it's come to
this but I'm going to do a temporary a
restraining order like leave me alone
wow they were trying to undermine a
Business Partnership and the legal
parameters they that they agreed to four
years ago and so yeah he's get he got a
restraining order against al Bubba Baker
his wife Sabrina and his daughter
Brittany for the allegations what were
they doing that was that like were they
bugging them too much or like so Mr John
is saying that they just get to unwind
poured business decisions through
slander's social media posts and and
those articles are no longer going to be
tolerated like we're not going to do
this anymore
um and it's just that it's just
slandering his name and like hey I got a
partnership with him you guys all saw
that on TV well guess what it sucked
It's like
because that also can affect the show
itself big time yeah and His Image and
FUBU and everything that he's so
basically they're just like saying like
yeah Damon was mean and he's out there
it's more like a defamation case exactly
I see and he wants a just a restraining
order just so they stop talking about
him right just like oh because I thought
a restraining order was just for
stalkers and [__] that's what I thought
yeah I never heard of it in this way
before so then you just can't even
address it yeah it's like leave me alone
like in social media and [__] wow
digitally restraining but the daughter
of Barbecue's uh boneless baby back ribs
continues to publicize the Shark Tank
business deal on social media causing
John to take legal action against the
family and she shared multiple email
Communications she's taking screenshots
between
um their business and and Mr John's
business partners
and uh they said that he modified the
terms of their initial deal continuously
ignored their complaints and included
them from important business meetings so
it sounds like just a really bad
marriage for business yeah I'm just like
confused is Damon out there like three
in the morning writing his own emails or
does he have a magic you know management
team that's doing this and then they're
not you know it's like I'm yeah I'm so
curious but they they did a lot of
things right so like the daughter also
shared audio of him actually talking to
them like regarding business concerns
it's like a private thing and you can't
post anything without playing someone
know you're taking them yeah
dang but this kind of makes me want to
try the ribs a little bit more a little
bit like I want to be like are the ribs
that good are the ribs yeah yeah and I'm
gonna eat it and then if it's really
good then I'll be like yeah I'm on their
team man you know most of those um don't
pan out isn't that crazy yeah most of
the shark tanks they don't even get to
the Business Partnership deal they
actually get vetted out behind the
scenes and then usually it doesn't work
out is it just because of the people
that come to the show just don't really
have their business stuff together or is
it just the statistic was it like 90 of
business fail within first five years
but it's not that because like they're
there to do a deal and then they get the
deal but the deal doesn't usually deal
doesn't matter oh somebody backs out the
Fulfillment it's like 30 of the time
like I guess it actually goes through
it's like 70 of time it doesn't you know
what's great is the people that most of
the people that don't get deals end up
kind of decent because they get a little
a little pop oh even for the the
products that they hate like oh I want
to try that yeah but they get exposure
so that damn that's the man that's the
driver then that um I saw an interview
with the the Barbara she's um she was
saying like
from the deals that she's done I don't
know if it's shark tank but in general
right she said like uh the Partnerships
the businesses like 70 of them just
didn't pan out like as in like they
didn't work out like they are she went
in Partnership she invested she did her
part she said yeah but the 30 that does
well like it makes up for the 70
failures yeah it sounds like why they're
there you know Mark Cuban's a
billionaire why is he doing a hundred
thousand dollar deals this is like maybe
this will pan out but then remember what
happened with was it Barbara and that
like Snuggie knockoff bro insane what
happened with that it crushed it
Millions she made Millions on that deal
it was a total knockoff it was like yeah
called something else but that's all you
needed and the Huggy yeah yeah and then
they were the rest of them you always
use her as the example of like that's
why we do it
because they all said no to that one
yeah and like we might as well try
they're actually the biggest deal ever
was the uh the [__] uh Scrub Daddy oh
yeah I Scrub Daddy that was like a
sponge dude it's just a [__] sponge
and ring cam what didn't ring cam go oh
you know I think what the [__] for real
ring count was another Powerhouse one
but it was called something else yeah
yeah but then they rebranded it he got
with Richard Branson he rebranded it and
like it killed it what was it called
before like ding dong it was like it was
like door I think it's called doorbot oh
I would have got I would have liked ding
dong better ding dong
ding dong ding dong
dingleberry uh dingleberry dog it makes
sense why most of them don't go through
because you're you only have what like
15 minutes to pitch yeah and then after
they pitch it then you gotta look at the
financials and then if you're actually
going through some sort of acquisition
Pro that could take much it's actually
so the edit is 15 minutes right but
you're actually it's actually multiple
yeah it's like over an hour easily
please put the interesting stuff they
cut they super cut to everything but
like a real deal could take months
though oh yeah and that's what happens
right so we see the televised portion
but then I'm behind the scenes there's a
vetting process and most people don't
actually make it through that their
numbers are weird the books don't make
sense yeah you know another show that I
really liked and I wish I kept going is
the profit with Marcus Lemonis oh yeah
that was a great show that was a really
good one I like that same setup no it's
it's completely different because Shark
Tank actually is I don't know if it's a
British show but I remember as a
Japanese one the Dragon one the Dragon's
Den yeah so that so I don't know what
came first I think definitely dragon's
death that yeah and then but the
Japanese one is it's [__] hilarious
dude because the [__] that they say
they'll talk [__] to like they'll be
like you better [__] pay what are you
gonna do if you can't pay me back
they're like wow
yeah they're like are you sure you're
gonna get this money back for me because
you know there's so many business people
out there that talk a bit gay but I
don't know about you and then like yeah
and then they beg for the money dude
it's so hilarious like they beg yeah
give it to me please
because the culture is different yeah
it's not like America where like you
have a more like a friendly environment
and equal human beings yeah it's like
this is my boss yeah
and then they roast them and I don't
know it's different yeah but the profit
was cool because the format was like a
distressed business will reach out to
him and ask them like we don't know what
to do it's like Kitchen Nightmares
record yeah yeah but what ends up
happening is he partnered he'll actually
give him an offer he'll own a part of
the business he'll come in fix it and
just rehab the whole thing right and
then there'll be follow-ups on the next
episode of past businesses and how
they're doing now oh follow-ups are cool
and then how it's tying into his whole
network the name was really bad though
calling it The Prophet yeah it was a bad
name that was cool I get the dobble on
yeah yeah double talk like my parents
don't even know what the [__] a profit
is either way they made a profit their
whole life and they don't trust psychic
people what do you think should the
Fixer-Upper yeah any honestly
doctorbusiness
just that's what it is sometimes you
just goes he comes and fix he has a
stethoscope and he's like or he has one
of the old ones with like the little one
that's true like the dog with Dr Mario
just heard it and you're like oh I know
what this show is about yeah say what
the [__] it is dude you know what's
funny is I saw a friend your friend uh
Jessica on the show
she was on the show yeah she actually
was in our old um where we used to have
they all JK office yeah because in one
of the episodes I was like this brick
building looks holy crap that's our
office and our neighbor right next to us
apparently it was like a yoga apparel
brand and then like you know that same
episode you know Steve's buddy she's
like a part of the yoga class that
they're do I was like what the [__] is
this no she's a yoga lesbian now dude
yeah straight up she's like married to a
woman and she's like a [__] yoga
person sometimes when you go yoga you go
lesbians it all started with a
wheatgrass shot and she never went back
yeah
foreign